il
[Musique]
nous sommes au coeur du domaine de
dampierre en yvelines le parc de 90
hectares a rouvert samedi 27 mars pour
l'occasion 25 mille bulbes ont été
plantés dans le jardin anglais parce
qu'elle thévard bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le directeur du domaine
une nouvelle aire de jeu a été ouverte
de quoi était le composent et oui pour
agrémenter la visite du public dans nos
90 hectares il y avait le parc floral
avec tous et merci c'est ces gens qui
essaient tudip qui ont été plantés comme
vous disiez mais il y a également au
delà dans une zone humide une aire de
jeu naturel qui a été réalisé à la
demande en fait du public depuis deux
ans maintenant que nous sommes ouverts
le public manquait trouvais qu'il
manquait des aides pour les enfants et
donc nous avions installé des aires de
pique nique mais au delà tout autour et
bien nous avons reconstitué avec des
graminées un labyrinthe alors les
graminées viennent des plantes et donc
tout ça ça va pousser au delà il ya des
cabanes en osier qui ont été plantés
donc c'est donc vraiment des plantes de
milieu humide parce qu'on a voulu
respecter le site
nous sommes un site classé donc on a
essayé de trouver des éléments qu'ils
soient le plus naturel possible et on a
complété lançant par un parcours en
poutres de bois posé au sol
et puis des billes de bois sur laquelle
les enfants alors quand quentin quand il
découvre ça ils s'amusent à sauter d'une
vie à l'autre et la pression de prendre
de la hauteur et d'évoluer au milieu des
arbres
oui c'est très sympa le le jardin
anglais aussi vu et ouvert là on est mi
avril
qu'est ce qu'on peut voir alors la mi
avril on est à la fin des narcisses et
des gens qui les tulipes commence depuis
quelques jours à vraiment prendre tout
leur coeur leur ampleur et cette
plantation de tulipes a été étudié par
nos jardiniers pour qu'on ait des fleurs
jusqu'au 15 mai puisque on s'est dit on
va sortir de l'hiver qui déjà était
morose
naturellement et puis ensuite avec cet
épisode de confinement on s'est dit il
faut que le public y trouve un intérêt
un attrait pardon à venir découvrir et à
avoir du plaisir à découvrir notre
jardin et donc on a des petits leap qui
vont continuer à fleurir au fur et à
mesure des semaines pour aller jusqu'au
15 mai après le 15 mai bien après ce
sont les feuilles aux arbres ce sont les
chaînes et les promenades dobraje et qui
prendront le relais
aviez aussi des calèches on pouvait
visiter le domaine en calèche est ce que
c'est toujours possible alors dans le
cadre de l'application des règles
sanitaires nous avons maintenu dans un
nombre limité les promenades de calèche
par contre nous avons arrêté
l'exploitation des rosalies aider des
golfs est fan des voiturettes
électriques parce qu'il fallait engager
une procédure de désaffection alors les
calèches c'est plus facile à désinfecter
les distances sociales sont mise
puisqu'on a limité le nombre et du coup
elle tourne et c'est aussi là aussi un
grand succès parce que me suis dit c'est
peut-être pas évident de d'ouvrir dans
la période de confinement dans un rayon
de 10 kilomètres et on a de fortes
demandes pour découvrir alors là on sort
des jardins et là on rentre dans le parc
forestier pas forissier ses 400 hectares
on ne découvre pas l'ensemble des 400
hectares avec la calèche
mais on en découvre au moins une
centaine supplémentaire donc sans plus
les 90 hectares de jardin si vous passez
une journée à dampierre vous découvrez
200 hectares de nature
en ce moment il est selon lui les bébés
sangliers sont en train d'être les faons
commence à changer leurs robes
voilà des découvertes sans cesse dans la
forêt comme dans les jardins
justement vous disiez avec le
confinement s'est limité à 10 km
finalement ce sont des visiteurs locaux
qui viennent ici ils viennent
redécouvrir peut-être ce jardin alors la
grande surprise pour nous c'est qu'en
fait ils viennent redécouvrir pour
certains mais ils viennent surtout
découvrir
c'est quelque chose qui m'a un peu
surpris
le jour de l'ouverture et des gens qui
sont venus nous voir en disant viens de
voisins-le-bretonneux on ne connaissait
pas dampierre et ils l'ont eu parce
qu'on a fait une pub dans un journal
local
et du coup ils sont ils ont vraiment
découvert aujourd'hui mais on va parler
de ce parc autour de nous parce que
c'est à nos portes
c'est dans le rayon des 10 km et on ne
connaît pas et donc pour nous en interne
ça nous permet de me permit de mener une
réflexion et donc du coup on en train de
fuite de
de commandos cibler notre public au sein
de ce rayon de 10 km pour montrer aux
gens dans l'essence dans 10 km on a
quand même cinq cent mille habitants
on n'imaginait pas vous avez le château
de vaux-le-vicomte chatouilleux oui
compte reste fermé puisqu'il n'y a
personne au tour nous les avons une
agglomération saint quentin en yvelines
avec près de cinq cent mille habitants
qui sont dans le rayon de 10 kilomètres
et donc c'est pour nous l'occasion de
ses rayons de 10 km est bien de
valoriser de faire de créer de la
notoriété de dampierre et de faire une
nouvelle activité pour des gens qui ne
connaissaient pas très va merci beaucoup
parce qu'un thévard d'avoir et les
autres invités
[Musique]
ans